alors que les fêtes de fin d'année vont
bientôt approcher il faut savoir que 2,8
millions d'enfants n'auront pas de
cadeaux à Noël comme l'an dernier et
parmi ces millions d'enfants il y a les
enfants vivant dans une famille
monoparentale 40 % d'entre eux vivent
sous le seuil de pauvreté 25 % des
familles en France sont monoparentales
83 % de ces monoparents sont des femmes
et 40 % de ces familles vivent donc sous
le seuil de P é par cet amendement que
nous déposons avec le président Boris
valallot les socialistes vous proposent
ce soir d'accorder une prime de fin
d'année une prime de Noël à toutes les
familles monoparentales aujourd'hui
bénéficiaairire de minimas sociaux que
ce soit le RSA laallocation de solété
spécifique ou encore laallocation
complémentaire retraite supprimée en
2011 nous vous proposons également
monsieur le ministre que cette aide soit
également apporté au bénéficiaaires de
la location adulte handicapé qui
aujourd'hui ne bénéficie pas de cette
prime de Noël par cet amendement nous
voulons donc donner un supplément d'âme
un petit coup de pouce à toute cette
famille qui galèrent et qui sentent
aujourd'hui qui vivent dans de grandes
difficultés c'est ce coup de pouce que
nous vous proposons à hauteur de 70
millions d'euros et qui apportera une
bonne nouvelle dans plus de 2 millions
de foyon français je pense qu'il y aura
unanimité sur tous les bancs sur cette
mesure on a indexé vous savez l'ensemble
des minimas sociaux c'est extrêmement
important donc c'est la raison pour
laquelle je donne un avis favorable pour
ce coup de pouce attendu la question des
des familles monoparentales elle est au
cœur des priorités de l'action de de
notre majorité et du
gouvernement je vous rappellerai à titre
d'exemple notamment l'intermédiation
financière pour les pensions
alimentaires la revalorisation de
l'allocation de soutien familial
l'extension du complément mode de garde
la possibilité de partage du complément
mode de garde donc nous adoptons tous
nos dispositifs à cette réalité de des
familles monoparentales vous proposez
sur la fin de gestion 2023 que nous
puissions accompagner davantage les
familles monoparentales à travers
notamment la prime de Noël c'est un avis
favorable du Gouvernement sur votre
amendement pour 123 contre 1 l'assemblée
nationale a
adopté